JOINED NOW BY MIKE FLORIO PRO
FOOTBALL TALK PRO FOOTBALL
TALK LIVE AND PRO FOOTBALL
TALK P.M. ON THE PEACOCK
NETWORK ALONG WITH THE RICH
EYES AND SHOW MY CUE ON DAN.
WHAT'S UP MAN? HOW ARE YOU
MAN? I HAVE BEEN READING YOUR
STUFF.
WHAT DID YOU START I 20 YEARS
AGO. HOW LONG IS PRO FOOTBALL
TALK BEEN AROUND I STUMBLED
INTO THE BUSINESS IN JUNE OF
2000 LAUNCHED PFFT NOVEMBER 1
2001. SO THE 20-YEAR NON
CELEBRATION IS COMING UP
LATER THIS YEAR THE 20-YEAR
NOT CELEBRATION GOLF CLAP FOR
YOU. MY FRIEND.
CONGRATULATIONS. IT IS A
MUST-READ HAD PETER KING ON
YESTERDAY AND PRO FOOTBALL
TOO MUCH STREETS ALL THE TIME.
LET'S LET'S DIG IN. I WAS
WATCHING A LITTLE BIT OF YOU
EARLIER TODAY WITH CHRIS
SIMMS ALSO A BIG FAN OF CHRIS
AND AND YOU TALK A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT THE DESHAUN WATSON
SITUATION WHICH CONTINUES TO
GET WORSE AND WORSE FOR
DESEAN AND I THINK THERE'S
NOBODY BETTER ON IN THE
COUNTRY TO TALK ABOUT THIS
SITUATION THAN MIKE FLORIO
SINCE YOU PRACTICE LAW FOR 17
YEARS IF YOU'RE HIS LAWYER
RIGHT NOW, WHAT DO YOU TELL
INTO SEAN WATSON TO DO I'M
TELLING DESHAUN WATSON? WHY
DIDN'T YOU LISTEN TO ME A
I TOLD YOU THAT WE SHOULD
SETTLE THESE CLAIMS NOW. I I
SAY THAT ONLY HALF THE
SEIZURE SLATE, YOU KNOW ANY
ADVICE I WOULD GIVE TO SEAN
WATSON WOULD BE PREMISED UPON
MY BELIEF THAT HE'S INNOCENT
OF WHAT HE'S ACCUSED OF DOING.
I WOULD NOT WANT TO
REPRESENT HIM IF I THOUGHT HE
WAS GUILTY OF WHAT HE DID AND
I UNDERSTAND THAT EVERYONE
HAS A RIGHT TO AN ATTORNEY
AND EVENTUALLY THERE WILL BE
IF YOU'RE PROSECUTED A
CRIMINAL DEFENSE LAWYER WHO
WAS THERE WITH THE MISSION OF
FORCING THE GOVERNMENT TO
PROVE ALL ELEMENTS.
OF ALL CHARGES BEYOND A
REASONABLE DOUBT. WE ALL HAVE
A CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT TO TO
JUST SIT THERE AND SAY
NOTHING AND FORCED THE
GOVERNMENT TO PROVE THAT WE
DID SOMETHING ABOVE THAT VERY
HIGH BAR IN A CIVIL SETTING
YOU DON'T HAVE THOSE SAME
PROTECTIONS IN A CIVIL
SETTING. IT'S A MUCH LOWER
STANDARD AND I WOULD NOT BE
AN EFFECTIVE ADVOCATE IF I
DIDN'T BELIEVE IN HIM
COMPLETELY AND ENTIRELY AND
FRANKLY IF I WERE CALLED IN
RIGHT NOW TO HELP DESHAUN
WATSON THE FIRST THING I
WANT TO DO IS LINE UP A
POLYGRAPH AND I'D WANT TO
MAKE SURE.
SURE THAT HE'S TELLING THE
TRUTH BEFORE I GIVE HIM ANY
ADVICE AND BEFORE I ATTACH
MYSELF TO SOMETHING THAT
ULTIMATELY WOULD AFFECT MY
REPUTATION MY INTEGRITY IF
I'M GOING TO STAND UP AND SAY
HE DIDN'T DO IT. THAT'S HOW
FAR THIS HAS GONE WITH 14
LAWSUITS AND 24 TOTAL WOMEN
WHO ARE MAKING THESE
ALLEGATIONS. I WOULD NEED TO
BE 100% CONVINCED THAT HE'S
INNOCENT BEFORE MOVING
FORWARD AND WITH EACH
ADDITIONAL LAWSUIT THAT
EMERGES I THINK IT'S HARDER
AND HARDER TO GET TO THE
POINT WHERE YOU WOULD BELIEVE.
EVE THAT NOTHING HAPPENED IN
EVERY SINGLE ONE OF THOSE
INSTANCES
FOURTEEN WOMEN AS YOU
MENTIONED 24 COULD EVENTUALLY
COME FORWARD ACCORDING TO THE
THE LAWYER. TONY BUSBY WHO IS
FILING ALL OF THESE LAWSUITS
FOR THE NFL. THERE IS AN
INVESTIGATION THAT IS THAT IS
ALREADY UNDERWAY. WHAT ARE
THE OPTIONS FOR THE LEAGUE AT
THIS POINT IF THIS PLAYS OUT
FOR A MONTH TWO MONTHS THREE
MONTHS THE NFL HAS VERY BROAD
POWER DOWN TO BASICALLY DO
SITUATION AND THE PERSONAL
CONDUCT POLICY IS SOMETHING
THAT WAS CREATED BY PR
CONCERNS 99.9 PERCENT OF THE
EMPLOYERS IN AMERICA. TAKE
THE POSITION THAT YOU KEEP
WORKING UNTIL YOU CAN'T WORK
BECAUSE YOU'RE IN JAIL AND IF
YOU PLEAD GUILTY AND YOU SERVE
PROBATION OR IF YOU'RE SUED
AND YOU LOSE THAT DOESN'T
AFFECT YOUR EMPLOYMENT THE
NFL CREATED A PERSONAL
CONDUCT POLICY THAT REGULATES
THE THINGS THAT PLAYERS DO ON
THEIR PERSONAL TIME WHEN THERE
NOT AT WORK, BECAUSE THE NFL
WANTS TO BE ABLE TO SAY WE
HAVE RESPONSIBLE MEMBERS OF
SOCIETY WHO DON'T GO AROUND
ENGAGING IN MISCONDUCT. SO
THE NFL HAS TO DECIDE AT WHAT
POINT THE PR CONCERNS REQUIRE
SOMETHING MORE THAN JUST AN
INVESTIGATION DOES THE NFL
REACH ITS OWN CONCLUSION,
WHICH THE NFL NOW DOES POST
RAY RICE THE NFL NO LONGER
DEFERS TO WHAT THE JUSTICE
SYSTEM ULTIMATELY DECIDES
WILL THE NFL DECIDE TO PUT
THE SEAN.
IT'S NOT PAID LEAVE WHILE
THESE 14 CASES GO FORWARD AND
WHATEVER PROSECUTION
POTENTIALLY MAY HAPPEN.
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT TONY
BUSBY'S TRYING TO INSTIGATE
IN HOUSTON. ALTHOUGH I DON'T
THINK PROSECUTION IS VIABLE
HERE BECAUSE OF THE VERY HIGH
STANDARD OF PROOF BEYOND A
REASONABLE DOUBT, BUT THESE
ARE VARIOUS OPTIONS AVAILABLE
THE NFL AND I THINK IT'S
DRIVEN BY WHICH WAY THE WINDS
BLOWING AND HOW HARD THE WIND
IS BLOWING AND HOW MUCH OF A
DISTRACTION THE NFL THINKS.
THIS IS BUT ONE POTENTIAL
OUTCOME HERE IS
THE TEXANS CAN
AND TRADE DESHAUN WATSON AND
HE GETS PLACED ON PAID LEAVE
AND HE GETS PAID HIS FULL
SALARY THIS YEAR TO NOT PLAY
FOR THE HOUSTON TEXANS WHILE
EVERYONE WAITS AND SEES HOW
THESE CASES PLAY OUT AND JUST
TO BE CLEAR MY PERCEPTION ON
EVERYTHING I'VE HEARD AND
READ IS THAT THE TEXANS
OBVIOUSLY AS THE REST OF US
TOTALLY BLINDSIDED BY THIS
RIGHT? THERE WAS THAT THEY
DID NOT SEE THIS COMING. THEY
DIDN'T SEE IT COMING. NOW.
THERE'S A FAIR QUESTION TO BE
ASKED ON WHETHER OR NOT THEY
GOT A HEADS-UP FROM TONY
VINCE BY HIS EXPLANATION AT
HIS PRESS CONFERENCE LAST
WEEK WHEN HE ACTED LIKE HE
DIDN'T KNOW THE FIRST NAME OF
THE GUY WHO OWNS THE TEAM.
YOU CAN'T BE A HOUSTON LAWYER.
VERY PROMINENT A GUY WHO RAN
FOR MAYOR AND NOT KNOW THAT
COW MCNAIR IS THE OWNER OF
THE LOCAL NFL TEAM WHEN HE
SAYS CAL OR HOWL OR WHATEVER
HIS NAME IS THAT TO ME IS
JUST ONE OF THOSE ONE OF
THOSE THINGS THAT DOESN'T GET
THROUGH THE CRAP FILTER AND
MAKES ME SAY SOMETHING'S
GOING ON HERE. AND THAT'S
SOMETHING I'VE BEEN TRYING TO
EXPLAIN TO PEOPLE. THERE
DOESN'T HAVE TO BE A
CONSPIRACY THEORY AT PLAY
HERE. IT'S AS SIMPLE AS
AS TONY BUSBY AS PART OF HIS
DUE DILIGENCE WHEN HE'S
EVALUATING THIS LAWSUIT
CALLING UP SOMEONE HE KNOWS
WHAT THE TEXANS AND JUST
SAYING. DO YOU KNOW ANYTHING
ABOUT THIS? IF YOU HEARD
ABOUT THIS KIND OF BEHAVIOR,
THIS IS A HEADS UP FOR YOU
THAT THERE'S AN ISSUE THAT'S
QUITE POSSIBLY GOING TO END
UP WITH A LAWSUIT BEING FILED
AND THEY CAN SAY THIS IS ALL
OFF THE RECORD THIS
CONVERSATION DIDN'T HAPPEN.
WE KNOW STUFF LIKE THAT
HAPPENS ALL THE TIME, BUT I'M
NOT BUYING THE IDEA THAT THE
TEXANS WERE CAUGHT AS
FLAT-FOOTED IS WE ARE I WOULD
GUESS THEY KNEW SOMETHING WAS
PERCOLATING BEFORE LAST
TUESDAY NIGHT WHEN THE FIRST
LAWSUIT WAS FILED DAN HELI
SITTING IN FOR RICH EISEN
TALKING TO MIKE FLORIO FROM
PRO FOOTBALL TALK AS A LAWYER
MIKE. YOU SEE THE WAY TONY
BUSBY HAS APPROACHED THIS
AND IT IS DESHAUN WATSON
BEING TRIED IN THE COURT OF
PUBLIC OPINION BECAUSE OF HOW
PUBLIC BUSBY HAS BEEN ABOUT
EVERYTHING POSTING A LOT OF
DIFFERENT THINGS ON INSTAGRAM
INCLUDING THE LETTER HE GOT
FROM
THE NFL SAYING THAT THEY WERE
BEGINNING TO INVESTIGATE
RIGHT WRONG IN DIFFERENT. HOW
DO YOU FEEL ABOUT HOW BUSBY'S
APPROACH THIS? I DON'T LIKE
IT. IT DOESN'T MESH WITH MY
OWN PERSONAL STYLE, BUT IT
HAS BEEN VERY EFFECTIVE IN
LARGE PART BECAUSE THERE'S
BEEN NO RESPONSE IN THE COURT
OF PUBLIC OPINION. IT'S
BASICALLY A NO-SHOW BY
DESHAUN WATSON AND WHOEVER IS
ADVISING HIM LEGALLY AND OR
ON A PR FRONT BECAUSE IT'S
BEN BUSBY UNREBUTTED GETTING
HIS MESSAGE OUT THERE.
SAYING THINGS THAT I DON'T
THINK ARE CREDIBLE WHEN HE
CALLS A PRESS CONFERENCE TO
SAY THAT THIS ISN'T ABOUT
PUBLICITY DURING A PRESS
ISN'T ABOUT PUBLICITY DURING
A PRESS CONFERENCE, RIGHT AND
WHEN HE SAYS IT'S NOT ABOUT
THE MONEY AND HE TRIES TO
CONVINCE THE AVERAGE PERSON
WHO'S LISTENING THAT WE'VE
ONLY ASKED FOR THE
JURISDICTIONAL MINIMUM TO GET
THROUGH THE COURTHOUSE DOOR.
WELL THAT GETS YOU THROUGH
THE COURTHOUSE DOOR AND USING
THOSE WORDS JUSTIFIES THE
COURT HAVING THE CASE IN THE
FIRST PLACE.
ACE BUT WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
LAWSUITS CAREFULLY, HE'S NOT
LIMITING ANY POTENTIAL
RECOVERY TO $500 WHICH IS THE
JURISDICTIONAL MINIMUM. HE
WANTS EVERYTHING HE CAN GET
THERE'S NOTHING WRONG WITH
THAT. THAT'S HOW THE CIVIL
JUSTICE SYSTEM WORKED. THAT'S
HOW THE POWERLESS GETS AN
EVEN PLAYING FIELD WITH THE
POWERFUL IF THE POWERFUL
WRONG THE POWERLESS THE
POWERLESS HAVE THE ABILITY TO
SECURE A VERDICT THAT FORCES
THE POWERFUL TO PAY AND
DETERS OTHERS FROM ENGAGING
IN SIMILAR BEHAVIOR, BUT FROM
A PR STANDPOINT SAYING
NOT ABOUT THE MONEY SAYING
IT'S NOT ABOUT PUBLICITY.
THOSE ARE THINGS THAT
PRESUMABLY ADVANCE THE CAUSE
AND AGAIN, IT'S WORKED BECAUSE
IT'S EVERYTHING BUSBY SAID
EVERYTHING THAT'S IN THESE
LAWSUITS UNCHALLENGED AND
UNREBUTTED IN THE COURT OF
PUBLIC OPINION. AND WITH SO
MANY PLAINTIFFS AT THIS POINT.
IT BECOMES VERY DIFFICULT
FOR THE AVERAGE PERSON. WHO
HEARS ABOUT THIS TO SAY
ANYTHING OTHER THAN HE HE'S
GUILTY AND AGAIN,
IN A COURT OF PUBLIC OPINION
THE JURORS ARE ALL OF US AND
THEY HAVE THE RIGHT TO REACH
WHATEVER CONCLUSIONS THEY
WANT WHENEVER THEY WANT LAST
QUESTION ABOUT THE WATSON
SITUATION FOR YOU MIKE IN
TERMS OF CIVIL VERSUS
CRIMINAL RIGHT NOW.
EVERYTHING IS CIVIL OBVIOUSLY
WOULD RATCHET UP IF IT
BECAME CRIMINAL CRIMINAL CASE
. IS THAT THE NEXT STEP HERE
FOR FROM FROM A LEGAL
STANDPOINT? WELL, THAT'S WHAT
BUSBY WANTS TO DO IS PART OF
HIS PR EFFORT AND
DOING THIS NOW. SEE IT'S VERY
BRILLIANT BECAUSE IT SHORT
CIRCUITS THE PR ARGUMENT THAT
SOME ARE MAKING AND THIS IS
NOT THIS IS NOT A VALID LEGAL
ARGUMENT, BUT THE WELL, WHY
DIDN'T THEY GO STRAIGHT TO
THE POLICE DEFENSE OR
SUGGESTION? WELL, THEY'RE
GOING NOW THERE'S NO
REQUIREMENT THAT THEY
IMMEDIATELY GO THERE GOING
NOW AND THEY'RE DOING IT
TOGETHER AND BUSBY IS
FACILITATING IT. HE'S ASKING
FOR THE LOCAL PROSECUTOR TO
INVESTIGATE THIS CASE AND
IMPANEL A GRAND JURY, BUT THE
UM, IS THIS THE PROSECUTOR
MAY LOOK AT THESE CASES AND
SAY HOW CAN I EVER PROVE
BEYOND A REASONABLE DOUBT
WHEN IT'S DESHAWN WATSON'S
WORD AGAINST THE WORD OF THE
PERSON REGARDING ACTIVITIES
THAT OCCUR DURING THE
INHERENTLY INTIMATE PROCESS
OF A MASSAGE. HOW CAN I PROVE
BEYOND A REASONABLE DOUBT
THAT HE CROSSED THE LINE AND
YOU KNOW PEOPLE THINK THE
JUDGE IN A GIVEN TOWN IS THE
MOST POWERFUL PERSON THE
PROSECUTOR IS THE MOST
POWERFUL PERSON THE JUDGE
ONLY.
EELS WHAT SOMEONE PUTS IN HIS
OR HER COURTROOM THE
PROSECUTOR?
THE ONE WHO DECIDES WITH
BROAD ALMOST UNFETTERED
DISCRETION WHO GETS
PROSECUTED AND WHO DOESN'T
AND MOST PROSECUTORS WILL
ONLY TAKE ON CASES THAT THEY
KNOW THEY CAN WIN.
LET'S MOVE ON TO FREE AGENCY
QUICKLY MIKE. THEY HAVE SPENT
A LOT OF MONEY HAVE THE
PATRIOTS AND AND THE GIANTS
AND I THINK EVERYBODY HAS
SPENT MORE MONEY THAN WE
ANTICIPATED PETER KING LAID
OUT HOW EVERY TEAM HAS A
THIRD OF THE MONEY TO SPEND
THAT THEY HAD A YEAR AGO YET.
WE'RE SEEING SOME MASSIVE
CONTRACTS HERE. IS THERE ONE
PARTICULAR CONTRACT OR MAYBE
TWO THAT REALLY CAUGHT YOUR
ATTENTION. WELL, YOU LUMP IN
THE GIANTS AND THE PATRIOTS
TOGETHER AND THEY'VE GOT THE
OBVIOUS CONNECTIONS FROM
THEIR PAST SUPER BOWLS, BUT I
CONTRACTS THEY SIGNED THEY
KNEW EXACTLY WHAT THE MARKET
WAS FOR THESE PLAYERS AHEAD
OF TIME SHOCKING TAMPERING
HAPPENS AND COMMUNICATIONS
HAPPEN BEFORE THE MONDAY WHEN
THE NEGOTIATING WINDOW OPENS,
I SUSPECT THAT THE PATRIOTS
VERY SURGICALLY MADE SURE
THAT EVERY DOLLAR WAS BEING
SPENT IN A WAY WHERE THERE
WASN'T MUCH OF A GAP BETWEEN
WHATEVER THE PATRIOTS OFFERED
AND WHATEVER SOMEONE ELSE WAS
GOING TO OFFER THE 2
CONTRACTS. THE GIANTS HAVE
SIGNED IN RECENT DAYS BETWEEN
KENYALA DAY AND A DORY
JACKSON. HE'S THESE GUYS
COMBINED TO PLAY IN EIGHT
GAMES LAST YEAR COMBINED
BETWEEN TWO OF THEM EIGHT
TOTAL GAMES AND YOU LOOK IT
OVER A HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS IN CONTRACTUAL VALUE,
AND I KNOW WITH GALAH DAY.
THERE WAS NO ONE ELSE
OFFERING CLOSE TO 18 MILLION
A YEAR. I DON'T KNOW WHO THE
GIANTS WERE COMPETING AGAINST
TO GET HIM. THE THE NEXT
CLOSEST THAT I'M AWARE OF IS
THE BENGALS AT 13 WITH
JACKSON. I DON'T KNOW WHO
ELSE WAS IN PLAY AND FOR HOW
MUCH BUT I HAVE A FEELING
THAT THEY OVERSHOT WITH THAT
AS WELL, YOU KNOW, SOMETIMES
SEEMS JUST LIKE LET'S GET IT
DONE. WE CAN'T WE
PLAY THIS GAME BUT WHO ELSE
IS OUT THERE? WE MAY LOSE THE
GUY BUT THAT'S THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN THE PATRIOTS IN THE
GIANTS TO ME. I SUSPECT THE
PATRIOTS GOT THE BEST
POSSIBLE DEAL. THEY COULD
WITH EVERY GUY THEY SIGNED
AND I'M JUST KIND OF
SURPRISED THAT SO MUCH MONEY
CHANGED HANDS WITH CALLED A
AND JACKSON GIVING THE INJURY
ISSUES THAT KEPT THEM TO TO
SUCH RELATIVELY SMALL PLAYING
TIME LAST YEAR. I TALKED TO
MIKE TANNENBAUM LAST WEEK ON
MY PODCAST AND HE SAID LET'S
TALK TWO WEEKS FROM NOW. HE
SAID I THINK I COULD BUILD A
PLAYOFF TEAM FROM THE NUMBER
OF FREE.
AGENTS QUALITY FREE AGENTS
THAT ARE STILL GOING TO BE
OUT THERE AND I'M LOOKING AT
THE LIST NOW AND I THINK
WE'RE ALL A LITTLE SURPRISED
BY THE NUMBER OF GUYS HAVE
BEEN SON. THERE'S NOT THAT
MANY QUALITY GUYS LEFT.
EVERYBODY HAS AN ASTERIX. I
THINK NEXT THERE NOW WHETHER
IT'S AGE OR COMING OFF INJURY,
ARE THERE ONE OR TWO GUYS
OUT THERE NOW WHO YOU THINK
ARE GOING TO BE THE NEXT
CHOOSE TO DROP FOR A DECENT
SIZED CONTRACT? WELL, YOU
KNOW WE'VE SEEN NOW THAT THAT
GUYS LIKE SAMMY WATKINS ARE
ARE BEING BROUGHT IN FOR
VISITS, BUT I DON'T EXPECT
HIM GET ANYTHING OUT OF HIM
ANYTHING MORE THAN A ONE-YEAR
MILLION-DOLLAR DEAL GIVEN HIS
INJURY HISTORY GIANT CONTRACT.
I JUST DON'T THINK THEY'RE
OUT THERE THIS YEAR, YOU KNOW,
IT'S IT'S GOING TO BE FOR
MOST OF THESE GUYS A ONE OR A
TWO YEAR THING. AND IF I WAS
THE PLAYER I WOULD WANT A
ONE-YEAR DEAL AND I WANT TO
GET RIGHT BACK AT IT NEXT
YEAR WHEN THE SALARY CAP
BEGINS GOING UP AGAIN, YOU
KNOW, EVEN THOUGH THE CAPS
DOWN 15 MILLION. IT WAS
SUPPOSED TO GO UP 10. IT'S
GONE UP AT LEAST 10 EVERY
YEAR SINCE 2013. IT'S A 25
MILLION DOLLAR GAP AND AND
YEAH, THERE ARE PLENTY OF
RECOGNIZABLE NAMES OUT THERE.
GOING TO GET SQUEEZED TO TAKE
LESS NOW. THEY MAY WAIT UNTIL
TRAINING CAMP. THEY MAY WAIT
UNTIL SEPTEMBER THEY MAY WAIT
UNTIL OCTOBER. THEY MAY WAIT
BEYOND THAT. I'VE HEARD SOME
SPECULATION. MAYBE GUYS WILL
SIT OUT THE WHOLE YEAR.
ALTHOUGH ONE THING WE KNOW
ABOUT THE NFL THE TRAIN KEEPS
ROLLING WITHOUT YOU AND YOU
QUICKLY BECOME OUT OF SIGHT
OUT OF MIND AS FAR AS THE NFL
IS CONCERNED AND I THINK EVEN
A GUY WHO ISN'T HAPPY WITH
WHAT HE'S OFFERED IF HE WANTS
TO TRY TO GET A GOOD DEAL
NEXT YEAR. IT'S IN HIS BEST
INTEREST TO FIND A PLACE TO
PLAY THIS YEAR.
LAST QUESTION FOR YOU, MIKE
DRAFT. WE'VE BEEN HEARING ADAM
SCHEFTER SAY THERE'S GOING
TO BE FOUR QUARTERBACKS IN
THE FIRST SEVEN PICKS. MY
TANNING. MOM TOLD ME HE
THOUGHT IN THE FIRST EIGHT.
WE'RE GOING TO SEE FOUR
QUARTERBACKS GO YOU WORK WITH
CHRIS SIMMS AND AND HE HAS A
VERY DIFFERENT COURSE.
A CRANKING THE SOME OTHER
GUYS, I BELIEVE IT WAS ZACH
WILSON OVER TREVOR LAWRENCE.
AM I CORRECT THERE? YEAH,
HE'S GOT ZACH WILSON AT
NUMBER ONE. HE STILL THINKS
THE JAGUARS COULD AND WILL
AND SHOULD TAKE TREVOR
LAWRENCE, BUT HE'S GOT WILSON
AT ONE. WHAT WHAT'S GOING TO
BE IN YOUR MIND. I'M ASKING
YOU TO BE A SOOTHSAYER HERE A
LITTLE BIT, BUT MAYBE
SOMEBODY WHO MOVES IN TO THAT
FIRST SIX OR SEVEN PICKS OR
SOMEBODY WHO PICKS A
QUARTERBACK THAT YOU DIDN'T
EXPECT TO PICK A QUARTERBACK.
WELL LOOK WHEN YOU
YOU WHEN YOU WATCH WITH THE
BEARS AND WASHINGTON HAVE
DONE OVER THE PAST WEEK BY
ADDING VETERANS AT 1 YEAR, 10
DOLLAR CONTRACTS AND RYAN
FITZPATRICK AND ANDY DALTON
THAT REMOVES THE GLARING WATCH
US TAKE A QUARTERBACK SIGN
THAT OTHERWISE WOULD BE
ATTACHED TO THEM WHEN WE
START GETTING THROUGH THE
TEENS AND THE QUESTION
BECOMES HOW MANY GUYS
SURVIVED THE FIRST FIVE SIX
SEVEN PICS HOW MANY
QUARTERBACKS ARE LEFT? HOW
MANY GUYS ARE SLIDING DOWN
THE BOARD AND I THINK THAT
YOU KNOW, THE
TEAM'S MOST
THE SURPRISES ARE THE TEAMS
WHERE WE THINK THEY HAVE
THEIR SITUATION TAKEN CARE OF
AND THEY'VE GOT A ONE-YEAR
BAN DAID STARTER AT A
RELATIVELY REASONABLE PRICE
FOR A STARTER. THOSE ARE THE
TEAMS THAT I WOULD BE
WATCHING. IF THERE'S SOME GUY
THEY LOVE AND OF COURSE THEY
NEED TO KEEP THEIR MOUTH.
SHUT OR PUT OUT
MISINFORMATION. THEY DON'T
WANT ANYONE TO KNOW EXACTLY
WHAT IT IS. THEY'RE THINKING
BUT I'D WATCH THOSE TEAMS
WHERE WE KNOW THERE ISN'T AN
ANSWER BEYOND THIS YEAR AND
THE ANSWER FOR THIS.
YEAR IS STILL A LITTLE BIT
TENUOUS? I THINK THOSE ARE
TEAMS THAT POTENTIALLY COULD
MOVE BUT YOU KNOW, HEY,
THERE'S THREE TYPES OF TEAMS
IN THE NFL TEAMS THAT HAVE
FRANCHISE QUARTERBACKS TEAMS
THAT ARE DESPERATELY LOOKING
FOR FRANCHISE QUARTERBACKS
AND TEAMS THAT HAVE A GUY
THAT THEY'RE NOT QUITE SURE
WHETHER OR NOT HE'S GOING TO
BE A FRANCHISE QUARTERBACK
AND THERE'S A LOT OF TEAMS IN
CATEGORY NUMBER TWO EVEN
TEAMS THAT HAVE STARTERS.
THEY DON'T HAVE FRANCHISE
QUARTERBACKS AND THEY'RE
ALWAYS LOOKING FOR THAT GUY
ONE TEAM. I THINK THAT FALLS
INTO THAT CATEGORY IS THE NEW
ENGLAND PATRIOTS RIGHT NOW
COMING BACK FOR A YEAR A LOT
OF PEOPLE PEGGING. MAYBE MAC
JONES TO GO THERE TALKING TO
SOMEBODY EARLIER TODAY SAID
THEY WOULDN'T BE SURPRISED IF
MAC JONES FELL OUT OF THE
FIRST ROUND, BUT I JUST FOR
ALL THE QUARTERBACK THIRSTY
TEAMS. I KNOW MAC JONES
DOESN'T KNOCK YOUR SOCKS OFF,
BUT I WOULD BE SHOCKED IF HE
FELL OUT OF THE FIRST ROUND
WHEN YA, HE'S THE KIND OF GUY
WHO ONCE HE STARTS CREEPING
DOWN THROUGH THE 20S, THEY'LL
BE SOMEBODY WHO SWOOPS IN TO
THE BOTTOM OF THE ROUND TO
GET HIM IN TO GET THAT FIFTH
YEAR OPTION ON HIS CONTRACT
SOMETHING WE'VE SEEN HAPPEN
HURLEY REALLY SINCE THE THE
2011 CBA THAT MADE EVERY
ROUND BUT ROUND ONE A
FOUR-YEAR CONTRACT AND GAVE
THAT 50 YEAR OPTION. WHETHER
IT'S TEDDY BRIDGEWATER LAMAR
JACKSON GUYS GO LATE IN
AROUND ONE BECAUSE IT GIVES
THE TEAM MORE FLEXIBILITY. SO
I WOULD BE STUNNED IF JONES
FALLS OUT AROUND 1:00. THERE
ARE PEOPLE WHO THINK HE STILL
GOES TOP 10. SO BUT THAT'S
PART OF THE FUN OF IT AND YOU
KNOW QUARTERBACKS ARE WHAT
DRIVE THE LEAGUE AND THERE'S
SO MANY GREAT YOUNG
QUARTERBACKS. THERE'S EVEN
MORE REASON NOW,
FULLY AND COMPLETELY VET THE
YOUNG QUARTERBACKS COMING IN.
WE'RE A LONG WAY REMOVED FROM
JAKE LOCKER BLAINE GABBERT
CHRISTIAN PONDER TAKEN 8 10
AND 12 AND 2011. AND THAT WAS
A TRUE ROLE OF THE DICE. THEY
KNOW THESE QUARTERBACKS A LOT
BETTER NOW THAN THEY EVER
HAVE BEFORE MIKE FLORIO. YOU
STILL BE ABLE TO DO
EVERYTHING FROM HOME IN WEST
VIRGINIA. I HAVE NOT TRAVELED
ON BUSINESS SINCE THE COMBINE
IN 2020. HOW ABOUT THAT? WOW,
I DON'T KNOW IF THAT'S GOOD
OR BAD. YEAH, ASK MY WIFE
QUESTION ANSWER QUICKLY
MIKE FLORIO PRO FOOTBALL
TALK PRO FOOTBALL TALK LIVE
PRO FOOTBALL TALK P.M. AT YOU
START TODAY AND YOU FINISH
THE DAY RIGHT HERE ON PEACOCK
WITH MIKE FLORIO HIGHLY
RECOMMEND YOU CHECK THEM OUT.
OBVIOUSLY, YOU'VE BEEN GOING
TO A SITE IF YOU'RE A
FOOTBALL FAN LIKE MYSELF FOR
20 YEARS NOW MIKE
CONGRATULATIONS ON THE
SUCCESS, MY FRIEND AND THANKS
FOR BEING THERE THAT I MEAN
LITERALLY I FEEL LIKE I I
CHECK YOUR SITE.
MUCH AS I CHECK MY STOCK
PORTFOLIO ON A DAILY BASIS
THESE DAYS. I'M VERY EXCITED
ABOUT. WELL, THAT'S VERY GOOD
AND YOU CAN NEVER LOSE MONEY
BY CHECKING MY WEBSITE.
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO LOSE ANY
I FEEL A LOT BETTER CHECK THE
PRO FOOTBALL TALK. THANKS